so we'll do this and go from there okay
so deep breath for me chief
uh how you doing tonight sir
uh do you have your driver's license and
insurance
where you come from tonight
i'm actually from
behind
my castles
okay
the reason why i pulled you over
you've been weaving quite a bit
well i know because i was eating
uh okay eating while driving okay
um well
how long's it been since your last drink
a couple hours a couple hours okay
um
i'm a police officer where you worked at
wood hazelwood
okay
how long have you been out in hazelwood
since 1979 oh wow
you're a police chief
there's one
all right
um well uh
chief um
say it's been a few hours since your
last drink you know how it is i just got
to make sure you're okay to continue
where do you live at
waterford crossing okay
um
how about
how about this chief just so i feel
comfortable knowing you're not
intoxicated and you're okay to go can
you uh can you just resize the alphabet
starting with letter d and ending on the
letter n without things so d to n
without singing
uh starting on the letter d and ending
on the letter n without singing so d to
n without singing
[Music]
[Music]
do you have your uh do you have your
police id and stuff with you
uh
greg hall says he's the chief of
hazelwood
so cheap before i can let you drive
i have to confirm you're not impaired
okay
so we could either start with the pbt
see if it's necessary to do field
sobriety or i could have you do some
field sobriety tests
either way i have to do
something before i can let you drive or
before we figure out something else
how much longer do you have
leftover hazelwood
pardon me how much longer do you have
left out at hazelwood are you just
nine months nine months
you ready to be retired
it's open
yeah yeah
it's uh i can only imagine how much
things have changed since you started in
law enforcement and
seeing the way it's gone
all right so we'll do this and go from
there okay so deep breath for me chief
i'm gonna hold it just blow hard until
that blow keep going keep going keep
going keep going up hang on a second
we'll try that one more time we're
almost there
deep breath for me blow hard until you
tell i tell you stop keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going
i will get it this time
just a little bit longer if you could
all right deep breath in and then just
blow hard
until i tell you to stop
all right um
hang tight right here uh i'll get back
with you okay
you just live right up the street
um
do you have your uh service handgun with
you in here
no you don't carry off duty no
no
all right um hank i'll be right back
with you
hey sergeant yeah
it's hard to get you over here but uh
you've made the big bucks so uh
uh so
chief hazelwood he is hammer drunk right
now
yeah
he's he's over two
he is hammered he was dodging sniper
fire out there so weaving all over the
place is it all on uh
is it all on the uh dash cam yeah the
driving and all the contracts so far
yeah
so
he lives
not too far from here up the street off
k i think
um
he's a currency yeah
because he's like six six to nine months
or something away from retirement
what's he said
what's that what is he said what's he
said yeah has he said anything is he
said that uh
he was coming from b hulls and went to
white castle to get some food and then
was heading home
so i have to do the alphabet
this is before i found out
anything and he said that uh
um
[Music]
oh i'm sorry he uh just complete
butchered the alphabet so
so i got through all that and then
you gotta feel spread i haven't done
field sobriety yet
just observations he's uh
yeah this is a tough day and age man you
know um
when you have
he uh on all these uh electronic things
and technology
i didn't like to handle anything else
all right your call
as eyes only
you would just
stare at the tip of my finger right here
okay
hmm
you you realize the position you're
putting up in right
i understand
i've been
i'm not doing anything
i'm sorry
hands down at your sides hang on one
second for me sir um just right foot in
front of your left foot heel to toe on
that line keep your hands at your sides
okay
i gotta chase
what's that
bad ankles how old are you sir
66 66
yeah
for being 66 you're in good condition
though
so right foot in front of your left foot
hang on one second form of chief
um i'm just gonna have you stand like
this or if you're not able to just stand
like that let me just go ahead and
explain demonstrate this test for you
okay sir
say that again uh so i'm just gonna have
you stand over there on the line i'm
just gonna explain and demonstrate this
test for you okay
so from your stance you're gonna take us
here's nine heel toe steps on that
yellow line okay when you get to your
ninth step you're going to leave your
lead fun line take a serious small step
nine yes correct
so when you get to your ninth step
you're going to leave your lead foot in
line take it serious small steps turn
around take another shears up nine heel
toe steps back on that yellow line okay
so
keep it'll look like this okay so
using your yo one
one
two
three so on and so forth until you get
to nine when you get to nine leave your
lead fun line take a series of small
steps
turn around take another series nine
heel toe steps back upon that yo line
one
two
three so and so forth
until you've completed the test thank
you
i just need you to remember hang on one
second for me sir i'm just
not able to do this
you know what
just thought that johnny
[Music]
i don't want to i really don't want uh
i also i mean you saw what happened in
in chicago right
with the with their uh chief police and
they they look i'm liable this is all on
camera
how's it how's that look if i don't do
my job
i
i'm gonna be honest her like this is a
really bad position to put me in
john nesky chief meske is on his way
okay and
he's top
he's on his way up here he's on his way
and uh we did our job
i'll find these like i said
yeah
i just
it's all being on camera i just don't
like hey chicago i'm sure you remember
when that whole superintendent i'm not
making this is not
you know uh i gave
i gave curt and i'm still recording i i
gave courtesy uh yeah to my supervisor
absolutely to let him know
this the the
the issue
and uh
because you know things like this are
cause
yeah no absolutely problems
absolutely so
i wanted him to be aware of what our
decision was and give him the
opportunity to
make a different one
or contact the chief of police
and he contacted the chief of police and
he lives down the street and he'll be
here shortly all right perfect
i will back you 100 any decision you can
make on that i appreciate it yeah
don't want to lock up a chief or another
hammer though he's hammered and he
doesn't have vgn this is a common thing
for him
oh really
well you know
unfortunately here's what happens
it'll probably kill him a bitch
because if
he
does this regularly
his body is going to be really good he's
obviously got an issue
yeah
i don't know hopefully uh
people get up here and decide but either
way um
yeah just hopefully
into retirement and he doesn't get
madness
hopefully we had i got family out in
florida last time i was out there
right i didn't see it it's not me
it's not you
and it's not
jordan
right now there's cruises
and there's a captain
and she
so
when we're done here i'm going back on
patrol
and i
our chiefs a day a week from retirement
nathan if i take him home or are you
gonna have any issues not at all
i'm sorry to get you out here i just no
no but i want to make sure that's okay
because you you do what you got to do
if you don't mind i will take him home i
know i have known him for a lot of years
yeah it's not understandable and and
again sorry to wake you up chief nope
nope nope that's okay he and i are gonna
have a long talk on the way home
you did your job